today we're looking at Network time
protocol and this is how you synchronize
a couple of computers well well in fact
the whole world uh potentially
I got into this um sort of by accident I
met Dave Mills who is the Godfather or
something of ntp he did all the early
work on it and I think he's still
involved sorry I happened to meet him at
a conference and he was telling me a few
anecdotes about it and so when I got
back home I thought all right I have to
have a play with this
because at the time we only had a few
computers slightly networked and it
didn't really matter too much whether
they were running at the same time
everybody you know just looking at
wristwatch typing the time that's that's
good enough
but there are some applications where
you really need the time to be a lot
closer particularly when you share file
systems so if one computer writes a file
and puts a timestamp on it and the other
one looks at it it's not too bad if this
one is behind that one but if it's ahead
of it this computer gets a bit confused
and says well this time hasn't happened
uh
and some will make crazy decisions based
on that particularly with the make
program that looks at time stamps a lot
so Dave Mills came up with this um
process to synchronize computers and I
sort of I remember chatting with him and
thinking
that's an interesting problem how do you
synchronize because if you go and talk
to that computer and say what time have
you got and it comes across and it says
you know the time is
10 32 and 57 seconds or something like
that you think well is that now or how
long has it taken to get from here to
there if I do it again it may well be
different because it may come out
quicker or it may come over slower
so um anyway that's that's kind of where
we got started with this and uh sorry
had a beer with him or something I I
forget it was a long time ago but uh
anyway so I thought it would be
interesting just to to show how this
this all works
so it's all based on an ntp packet so
there's a this is 32 bits I think across
here so there's a whole lot of little
flags and bits which you often get in
protocols in the very first bite that
tell you I think this is the version and
this this one actually tells you where
there's a leap second happening today
because it even caters for that and
there's a stratum here and I think
that's the version I forgot what goes in
there but it's not quite so important
then there's some other stuff but the
key bit are some time stamps that come
in so there's a t naught T1 T2 and
there's also a T3 but that doesn't
actually appear in it and then there's
some other stuff down here which is to
do with authentication and authorization
so if you need
to make sure that you're not getting
bogus packets from places so this didn't
used to be in the first version because
everybody trusted everybody back in the
year
back in the day but uh since then
everybody's got much more
um
focused on security
so what you do to synchronize clocks is
we have a client on the server and the
client wants to synchronize to the
server
so it sends out a packet with its t0
which is uh this is my time this is what
I think my time is
and as soon as it arrives into the
server it stamps it with T1 that's the
service time so this would then T1 minus
t0 is is how long it took to get across
there that would be if the clocks were
right yes but but at this point they're
not right we're almost always the case
so then it does some processing
internally because it might be handling
lots of things and then eventually it's
going to send back a packet and it will
put T2 in which is my time when I have
actually sent this out and when it comes
back in that you do record when it comes
back in T3 and you don't need to fill it
into the uh the protocol packet because
you're finished with that so you can see
probably that these two times on the
same machine so they are relatively the
same you know if you subtract T3 minus
t0 then that's how long this whole thing
has taken but you can improve that by
also removing the T2 minus T1 because
that's how long it took to process that
this gives you a fairly good estimate of
the round trip
minus the service processing and then
the the difference in clocks is uh T1
minus t0 you know this is
the service clock and my clock and you
know that that equals zero then they're
synchronized it never does but you want
to get closer and closer to that
so it's uh I guess if it's negative it's
one way and if it's positive it's the
other way you then have to adjust your
clock and say
oh we're out by three or four seconds so
that's usually where you you apply this
clock skew algorithm to say right keep
we're a bit ahead so keep taking instead
of every second moving on a second we'll
move on you know 0.99 of a second and
eventually we'll get closer and closer
to the real thing
that's actually now a system call to do
that so that in certain unixes anyway
believe Windows has something similar so
that you don't get these huge jumps in
time that uh time moves slowly and
imperceptibly onwards but to get it even
better you do this a number of times and
you also do it to a number of servers if
you can so you get a sense of different
times from different servers and they
should all be fairly close if they're
all sort of playing the game
but some of them you will get much
better uh round-trip times
but more importantly some of them you'll
get a very stable round trip time so it
doesn't vary you know if one takes a
second and then the next one is five
seconds you never quite know where you
are so it has within the uh the protocol
or the
protocol State machine a way to work out
which is the best and say well this this
one is a very good source of time
but it's um it's moving around too much
so I'm not going to trust that the
communication links are just too bad
it's perhaps in
South America or somewhere like that but
this one is not quite as good but at
least it's stable and this is where the
stratum comes in this St so you can have
16 stratums I think what does stratum
mean then so zero stratum is a is a
really good clock so it's like an atomic
clock or a GPS clock or something like
that and the stratum one is a computer
that's using one of those to synchronize
itself so you never actually talk to a
stratum zero and the stratum two is
something that's synchronized for
stratum one and a Stratton three to just
kind of tops away from the from the
sources yeah so that all sort of feeds
into it it would prefer to synchronize
to a stratum one because you're closer
to it but this Jitter and the fact that
um quite a lot of the stratum one clocks
are kind of a bit locked down don't
trust anyone because otherwise everybody
would sink right to that so you you go
backwards and forwards between them how
often is this happening uh happens quite
quickly initially I think it's every
minute but once it's settled down decide
where it is it slowly backs off until
it's about every 10 minutes it sends a
packet out and says are you still right
because by now it's synchronized it but
not in originally we had
connections across the internet to just
one place that had one of the Estrada
one or two things so we were setting it
from that and then we're Distributing it
all around the department because we
only had a very thin wire at that point
which was great because you so you'd see
the Stratton One come in and we would
all be stratum too because we were
connected to that but when you lose that
connection it's quite interesting what
happens so each of the computers looks
around and says oh I've lost that one
but there's a whole load of stratum twos
around here so I'll synchronize to one
of those and they're all saying oh yes
there's a I lost that but there's a
whole load of stratum twos so I'll
synchronize to that so that makes me a
three and this one says oh that was a
two minute ago it's now a three so I'm
now a four and this one says well that
that's a four one out so I'm a five so
they move up until they get to 16 and
then they sort of they kind of tap out
at that point and say
well yeah there doesn't seem to be
anything uh anything reliable anymore so
that's kind of where where they give up
on that and how accurate can it be it
can get very very accurate you can
certainly get to milliseconds or or even
better now I think I think the protocol
has it down to microseconds what are the
things in my late night conversation
with Dave Mills is he spent half his
life I think watching clocks and seeing
how they drifted so when the UK first
came online and started synchronizing he
was watching uh some of the early
traffic across that and he noticed at
sort of five o'clock all the clocks
started to drift
and then they sort of got back into sync
at about seven o'clock only by small
amounts and uh this was because you know
that is when everybody gets thrown from
work puts the kettle on the power grid
suits up and the 50 hertz signal slowly
moves slightly as they try and maintain
the grid level but that influences the
clocks so the clocks will sort of drift
and then when the load diminishes they
put it up a bit so all the clocks move
back a bit but he said I can tell you
know I can tell when coronation streets
are holding on I can tell when the uh
the adverts are on because I can see see
this Gap so for those not in the UK
these are kind of popular soap operas
television with a break halfway through
that everybody rushed out and put the
kettle on to have a cup of tea you know
being British
so he could detect that he reckoned them
in one case there was an earthquake in
San Francisco I think
and he said the clocks went a bit spooky
beforehand I could see them drifting
around I wonder if I've got an
earthquake detection through eyes I
don't think he ever followed that up
but there's a few cases like that where
he said you know I could see strange
things happening because I got this high
level of precision
fun for Robotics and for problem solving
which is your by choosing the car 10 of
your Journeys take you 71 days die a b c
and d
and I tell you that die a has a value of
4. how much did you learn about the data
set